when a movie is brought to a television
distributor uh what type of advance
should a filmmaker expect
all over the map if uh
all over the map there are films that
it's becoming more and more common that
films are
are represented on a revenue share which
is just a split of percentages
there's a lot of situations where an
upfront
called a minimum guarantee or mg is paid
and that can be a good faith mg
of 10 15 000 it can be a massive mg
of 100 200 sometimes 400 thousand
dollars if all rights are being acquired
and then percentages on the back end
there can be an outright purchase which
is really really high
uh the story that most people know from
the 90s in the sundance era
with uh you know when the weinsteins
were miramax and not the weinstein
company
um it was the idea that you could an
independent could bring a movie to the
marketplace
that no one had ever heard of before
that there's no cast names in it or
anything like that and that like huge
dollars would just be put down that's a
different era it doesn't exist today
films are not marketed the same way
today and so the value of films is
completely different
and besides technology's dramatically
increased so
with advances in technology films are
much cheaper to produce
more people are producing them there's a
huge overabundance of films out there
and so the value of putting down large
sums of money has actually gone down
quite a bit
so in a very short answer it's all over
the map
it depends who's in it depends what
genre it is depends
the quality depends
if it's fully deliverable if the movie's
not fully deliverable like if it doesn't
have all the the legal elements on the
back end
that's problematic and it's a deal
breaker and i
have some other writings that i'm
putting together on that specific point
actually
about how to make a film deliverable
these are all
elements that can put the price tag of
what a movie is worth to a production
company
in completely different quadrants and
i'll tell you this
we we run very very detailed analytics
on every film so when we review a film
we will have it screened by several
different people
and we do compensations to other
projects we do
very detailed assumptions projections of
what we think the film is worth
and so when we give percentages and
price tags on movies
we've done a lot of research to come up
with those numbers and it has to be
incentivizing to us and it has to be
incentivizing to the producer
and uh you know we put a lot of
calculation into finding that middle
ground
and this is all like computerized data
it's watch time and where someone
may have dropped off and it's it's all
in that and it's also
um it's all in that and it's also just
in general like
experience of uh knowing how films move
you know i've been international sales
for a long long time i've been in
domestic sales in north america for a
long time i've been
in meeting rooms and presented projects
and i've seen faces wince up when i
present a project that i thought would
sell really well and i've seen
excitement over projects i didn't think
stood a chance and i've developed a very
good barometer
about what movies work what what doesn't
work
as has anyone in this business who's
been around for a while you just you
learn what makes sense what moves the
needle and what doesn't
and so all those are factors into what
gives a film a price tag so
when a producer has this wild assumption
that his movie is worth
five hundred thousand dollars two
million dollars or something ridiculous
when it's just not
if he's getting offers that are just
revenue shares or very very very small
mgs there's a very logical rational
mathematical answer to why
you